this is a nice easy introduction to this
topic because remember we just said
refused
what was our sitting in for racial is a
fraction like they're just fractions
dressed up in different clothes okay
so one of the first examples they've got
is here we go example 2 to 7 that's the
way I read that by the way I might even
write that on you the way I say this is
2 to 7 okay so for every 2 of something
I've got 7 of something else ok that's
equal to and the ratio that comparing us
to is something 235 right now this this
is exactly the same as number 3 this
question you see how every writer in
fraction form you know perfect ok so you
can see this is a question you are very
familiar with we should be really good
at it what do we do to get to this
unknown yeah
that's it so I'm rich here a new one D
is 10 to 35 ok so the kinds of places
where this appears is like if you are
cooking you're making a recipe and it's
like oh this is a recipe for you know 10
people 10 people ok and you need 2 cups
of flour 7 cups of water something like
that that's not gonna be very useful
it's like ok knows you for you anyway if
that's for 10 people but you wanted it
for more people maybe 50 people you're
going to have a new race here right I'm
now gonna have 10 cups of this 35 cups
of that you see the comparison okay now
really quickly watch out I am this is
not from the book but I'm doing examples
who occasionally you'll get fractions
appearing in your ratios right so you
might get something like this 6 and 2/3
to - okay and rather than being told ok
here's a new you know number to put on
the denominator just like here all they
want you to do
it's just simplify it just write it
without fractions in the ratio because
that's kind of like fractions on
fractions right so what might we do here
to get rid of that over three inputs
just make it uh okay first step I'm
going to do is make this convert into an
improper fraction how do I do that again
yep so it kind of looks a bit like this
you might have drawn diagrams a bit like
this right and the reason why is because
you're 2/3 here how many thirds are in
six birds there are 18 thirds okay
so 18 thirds plus two that gives me 20
20 and told 20 thirds right that's that
number the list hasn't changed I've just
sort of dressed it up a little
differently so the two is still there
now what do I have to do yeah
okay so yeah I don't want this to be
2003 I want to be 20 over 1 okay so to
get it to be a 1 I've got to multiply
this fraction by 3 right so let me even
write this as an extra step I'm going to
multiply by 3 which means I'm going to
multiply this by 3 do you see that okay
so on the left hand side of the ratio I
just get 20 and what do I get on the
right 6 okay now that's better
it's all whole numbers but I can do even
better than that can i yes I can
simplify further my clothes food yeah
because these two have a greatest common
divisor of two so I'll divide through we
accuse me 10 and 3 2 3 okay just pause
pause before you pack up and go home do
a sense check on this because ratios are
very common sense 10 to 3 does it
roughly look like what we started
yes enjoy the rain and the third is
equivalent to one third okay yeah so in
my head what I'm thinking of just just
go a common sense check only needs to be
approximate how much bigger roughly
roughly how much bigger is ten than
three it's about three times bigger but
about three times become a little more
isn't it is this about three times
bigger than two yeah it is thumbs up
we're in the right track okay you'll
often know you've gone wrong because
sometimes it'll be like backwards
oh I'm three times smaller but what I
started with was the other way around
common sense checks can really save you